bonjour mourad debbabi vous êtes doyen
de la faculté d'ingénierie de
l'université concordia à montréal
il vous êtes expert en cybersécurité or
on vous êtes là avec nous pour nous
parler du lancement de l'application
alors qu'on vit ici au québec c'est une
application qui est annoncé par le
gouvernement pour tracer la propagation
et pour arrêter et rasé en même temps la
propagation du de lakovic merci d'avoir
accepté de venir nous l'on parle merci
beaucoup c'est mieux alors monsieur
mambe on va commencer directement que
swing implications sécuritaires sur un
téléphone portable
c'est quoi une application sécuritaire
samian imagine une application est dite
sécuritaire s'est elle ne protège très
bien les données qui sont collectées et
il veut donner pour magasiner sur le
téléphone le dispositif aussi c'est une
application qui sécurise les
communications avec les autres
téléphones ou ordinateurs ou machine cie
aussi une application qui a un certain
capacité à protéger la vie privée de
l'utilisateur et aussi à faire face à de
possibles attaques émane de l'intérieur
ou de l'extérieur du téléphone or
musulmans de bébé vous appartenez aussi
au consortium nationale de cybersécurité
il récemment ce construction a émis
quelques directives
vous pouvez nous les énumérer un peu des
plus importantes est ce que vous pouvez
nous décrire c'est quoi ce consortium le
en quelques mots le consortium est une
organisation à but non lucratif qui vise
à faire avancer l'agenda de cyber
sécurité et de protection de la vie
privée au canada
elle regroupe plus de 140 professeurs et
experts en sécurité et en protection de
la vie privée à la gare et elle vise à
promouvoir la collaboration entre
secteur privé et public et institutions
académiques dans le domaine de la
sécurité
et récemment ce consortium a émis
quelques directives pour définir c'est
quoi une application sécuritaire est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner quelques
quelques-unes de ses directives
oui et le consortium a émis un document
qui articule dix principes
de bonnes pratiques en matière de
conception d'applications de traçage en
fait parmi ces principes c'est un examen
par des experts indépendants en
cybersécurité et en confidentialité de
la vie privée une conception simple qui
permet la validation de l'application
des fonctionnalités minimales une
collecte minimal de donner une bonne
gouvernance des données collectées aussi
une application qui dotés de mécanismes
de super sécurité qui protège les
données et des échanges aussi une
protection des données dérivés et est
aussi une application qui arrive durée
de vie limitée
c'est à dire qu'il ya une date prévue
pour son extension
or le gouvernement canadien a lancé dans
quelques provinces
une application qui fait le traçage des
cas cowitz et l'application à la vie est
ici
récemment aussi au québec est ce que
vous avez eu accès à ces applications
comment elle fonctionne et cette
implication comment fonctionne l est et
l sécurité de selon votre point de vue
d'expérience merci dame en application
dans sa conception elle est très très
simple et comme je les mentionnaient
aussi elle est très très sécuritaire et
respectueuse de la confidentialité de la
vie privée l'application elle utilise le
protocole de tout et quand une personne
qui activent l'application sur son
téléphone se trouve à proximité d'un
autre utilisateur qui à l'application
sur son téléphone et les gens se produit
de nombreux lots aléatoires
c'est une séquence de chiffres donc qui
sont échangées et ils application à l es
tu lis ces chiffres là qui sont échangés
à des stores pendant une durée de 14
jours
et si un jour une personne est infectée
reçoit un code d'une organisation vous
sentez dans la province à personne
rentre le camp le code est donc les clés
qui sont utilisés pour générer ces
chiffres allaient axe doit aller voir
son communiqué à un serveur fédéral
et là c'est juste une séquence de l'ong
qui contiennent aucune indication sur
l'identité des utilisateurs de ces
applications là donc les utilisateurs
quotidiennement ils téléchargent ces
clés cryptographiques
il les utilise pour calculer ces
chiffres seront aléatoires
ici on trouve par exemple entre ceux
calculés avec ses clefs là et ceux qui
sont sur les téléphones ayant une
correspondance ça veut dire qu'on a été
en contact avec quelqu'un qui a été
déclaré positif pour le virus donc dans
ce cas la personne va va faire les tests
et chercher l'aide médicale nécessaire
et ses clés qui sont stockés dans un
serveur du gouvernement ce que
sécuritaire aussi je pose la question
est ce qu'elle laisse pas d'être athées
etc on retrace les gens et que quelqu'un
sache qui est malade qu'il n'est pas
malade
d'abord d'avoir les clés cd créer des
clés cryptographiques les
cryptographique ses deux congénères
souvent qui est aussi les chiffres là
qui sont échangés un pillage les roaring
proximité avec indifférence cd dans ce
dossier at war parle d'abord ils sont
stockés de manière sécuritaire
mais même si ils sont divulguées ils ne
contiennent aucune indication sur
l'identité des utilisateurs
puisqu'on parle de technologie de l'auto
de cette technologie qui est qui n'est
pas très puissante derrière sa porte et
n'est pas très puissante parce qu'elle
risque d'erreur c'est à dire que je que
je peux je croise réellement quelqu'un
de malade mais mais tellement sais c'est
pas très puissant donc le système ne dis
pas que je te croiser premièrement de
nos jours la technologie bluetooth elle
est utilisée de manière intensive
tous les gens qui qui utilisent les
oreillettes la bluetooth et en
l'utilisent de manière intensive les
claviers qui se connectent à des
ordinateurs de deux dans citi
technologies kiki qu'on a eu le temps de
la parfaire et elle est la fiabilité une
grande fiabilité de nos jours mais même
s'il ya une petite marge d'erreur ça va
à nuire au bon fonctionnement de
l'application
il ya des gens qui ont peur de vivre
dans un monde de big brother à la george
orwell où le gouvernement oblige les
gens à installer cette application est
que
et que supposons qu'ils reçoivent le
code de le code de fonctionnement le
code alerte il de m obligé de mettre
sinon on va adopter une loi qui va les
punir est-ce que ce scénario est
possible
honnêtement avec cette application comme
je vis cette implication son compte de
source
il est disponible les gens peuvent le
regarder il ya de la documentation est
disponible et en vàd rire des plaignants
il ya aucune manipulation d'informations
sensibles dans cette application n'a
donc elle est sécuritaire et comme j'ai
dit elle a reçu l'aval d'autorités
gouvernementales comme le centre
canadien de cybersécurité sécurité qui
est une autorité nationale en matière de
cybersécurité mêmes
même les commissaire à la vie privée
aussi bien au niveau fédéral qu'au
niveau provincial
ils ont aussi témoigné du bon
fonctionnement sécuritaire et
respectueux de la vie privée de cette
application
donc honnêtement le risque est très très
très minimal avec l'utilisation de ces
applications
j'imagine que vous avez fait vos
lectures vos recherches vous êtes expert
comment est-ce que cette application
concrète et installer ailleurs dans le
monde et ce qu'elle a été efficace c'est
ce qu'on a pu mesurer son efficacité
j'ai entendu dire qu'elle a été installé
aussi en corée du sud
si je me trompe pas moi moi je me
questionnais moi je n'ai pas des données
gouvernementales d'autres pays mais ce
que j'ai c'est des publications de
recherche dans des revues qui sont
hautement respectueuse et bien établie
il ya des études qui ont été publiés qui
démontre que l'application est là à
partir d'un seuil d'utilisation de 15%
elle peut avoir un impact hautement
significatif donc quelle portion de la
population voulait dire un sponsor de la
population en fait ici positif donc elle
peut la mettre de de décider des cadres
qui ont été exposés au virus et donc on
peut intervenir assez rapidement pour
leur donner l'aide médicale nécessaire
donc j'imagine que vous suivez aussi
l'évolution de cette application ici au
canada
vous avez des chiffres sur son adoption
serait ce que des qualités
eux ont été décelés grâce à ça
honnêtement je n'ai pas des données à
cet égard vous semblez faire très
confiance à cette application est ce que
vous vous lavez installé sur votre
téléphone
oui bien sûr je les ai installés et je
la recommande très vivement g j'ai émis
quelques publications sur les réseaux
sociaux pour dire que j'ai regardé de
très près le design de cette application
anda et moi j'affirme et je témoigne
qu'elle est très bien faite et qu'elle
est sécuritaire et elle protège la vie
privée merci beaucoup
professeur de baby je rappelle que vous
êtes le doyen de la faculté d'ingénierie
de l'université de concordia et expert
en cybersécurité rcp